this is one thing apparently that we
never got around to doing over the
summer break and that was the photoshoot
for season 2300 it took 11 minutes for
an eye-roll to happen I thought we're
off to a great start this season who did
it minutes and we had ad stuff as always
me and a bad kid what was your mood
coming back to the table this season
yeah we start I need a warm-up you know
you just sort of thrown into it after a
whole month of laying around doing
nothing I can't I can't see the light no
more everyday I'm wearing glasses even
if I don't need them yeah
because I can't stand the light or the
shade do you know the shade it's like
jelly
Oh a throwing shade oh she likes to use
that phrase did I just throw shade in so
cute because people really they see you
guys get frustrated each other of our
topics and then you're fine backstage
you and I are like the least of all the
people backstage you actually get along
the best because we always want to watch
news after and still talk about yeah
it's true anything breaking news I'm
like joy what's going on and normally we
disagree but it's still there's a lot of
good stuff coming up I always thought
they should have us moderate the debates
instead because you're gonna get first
of all we're not gonna be us anyone I
was my swear I'm sorry and then we're
also gonna ask all the questions that I
think both extreme sides of the party
want to know and I think it's important
I think that's a great idea
I meant they're too scared of us they're
scared of us what you ask my Republicans
don't come on the show why not
Republicans come on the show because
it's not always a nice environment
Republicans but I also think that if you
can't come and do our table you'd have
no business being in politics or elected
office or god forbid the presidency
because if this scares you you've got to
grow up
it really got a girl who can't handle
the view handle 20 mega you shouldn't be
running for office
okay so join the the viewers gonna
celebrate it's 5,000 show this season do
you have a favorite view moment when you
think of my life on the view my favorite
moment is when I walked off the show
when Bill O'Reilly was on the show
[Applause]
that was my tip top moment that when I
drop dead I want that on my she walked
off the stage when that fascist said
what he said that's what I want that's
all walked out on my toes like Jennifer
Lopez or like you know I need the Cuban
celebrity guy no it was looks like it
was like my big moment well no I didn't
quit they fired me let's get this
straight I did not quit now I was fired
I was summarily dismissed and then I was
they begged me to come back and Here I
am yeah have you heard from who's not
the show without joint honestly I mean
you're the og and she has a huge huge
fan base following yes
as yes you know you do because I like
the Facebook groups that are joy there's
a few Facebook groups that I say joy is
the best part of the view and then they
try wouldn't allow but I don't want them
to know I'm reading it I don't really
really involved in show me stuff but I
don't follow Twitter or any of them tell
me that's going into this season do you
talk to Barbara did she still watch the
show exam Oh Barbara Walters one time I
said to Rosie I said well Barbara you
know bump up I said Barbara Walters and
she goes no strikes and I'm gone
so no Barbara Walters alright and you
know I think I think oh yes she does
watch cuz I ran into her assistant
resolution that she watches the show
yeah
[Music]